it was the end of a very stressful
summer and I was not at my peak I've
been working 60 hour weeks I wasn't
feeling appreciated at work and I said
that's it I need a vacation can anyone
else here relate with that everyone the
irony was is that I was in the vacation
business we need vacations they give us
better health they make us more
productive at work and studies show that
the best ones are when we go further
away from home and when we take more
time off so we should go traveling on
vacation problem is we don't get a lot
of vacation days out of 137 countries
that mandate paid leave the United
States is not one of them the European
Union requires 20 days of paid vacation
France and Finland get 30 Afghanistan
gets 35 days of paid leave so we should
be furious we're being deprived of our
best days there's a sad reality we don't
even take the vacation days that are
given to us in 2014 forty-one percent of
Americans didn't take a single day off
and that year we left 500 million days
on the table unused I don't get this I
love vacation so much that when I
graduated college I moved to a ski town
and I pretty much made vacation my
full-time job maybe people aren't seeing
the value in vacation that I see when I
saw a study that said that people are
happier when they're planning a vacation
then when they're actually on it I knew
there was a problem to illustrate this
let's go on a vacation together so we
start planning we look for inspiration
we look at private beaches always sunny
days you see a gorgeous couple falling
madly in love in the sunset and you
think that could be me I just have to go
from point A
boring stressful home or school and got
a point B where the land is magical and
everyone's happy so we start our trip
flight was only slightly delayed most of
your bags made it and then you get in
the taxi and you're pretty sure you got
ripped off CF day means seventy dollars
right but the hotel pool is just as
promised you get to your room though and
your toilet looks like this so you're
stressed out you sit down in your chair
you pull out your phone and if you're
like 70 people seventy percent of people
on vacation you check your work email
and that really angers you so then you
go to Instagram and you realize oh my
gosh my friends are having a much better
vacation than I you are now experiencing
what we in the travel industry like to
call disappointment and this is when
your expectations are much higher than
your reality I asked my business school
friends why do you all like to go on
vacation and the overwhelming response
was that they like to relax why would
anyone go and want to go on vacation if
that was your reality my private equity
friend says that she loves to go on
cruises because she gets to chill out
and do nothing my consultant friend
echoed this and he said that his days
are so hectic that he just likes to
disconnect and do nothing there has to
be something more to vacation than
nothing what I was hearing from my
classmates is that they were treating
vacation as a painkiller to deal with a
psychological stress of their work when
I could see vacation as a vitamin to
enrich their life but how could I convey
this to my consultant friend he spoke a
foreign language so i made a 2 by 2
and we decided that the best trips were
both pleasurable and memorable and we
would plot the data based on how you
would answer the question how was your
vacation so the bottom left quadrant
we've got the one that we planned
together it's okay and then on the top
left private equity girls dream
all-inclusive trip you say ah but it's
not a trip you're going to tell your
kids about ten years now the bottom left
quadrant this is the danger zone this is
where hypothetically you have to spend
the night with the Russian Federal
Police and then the next day on the way
home you get strip-searched not once but
twice in Israel don't ask the top left
that must be what we're looking for
amazing is there reflected back on my
own travel experiences I realized that
the majority of my trips were amazing
but some were better than others some
were more impactful and I couldn't put
my finger on what that was no textbook
on the tourism industry would be
complete without a chapter on Abraham
Maslow psychologists who studied
motivation in humans he created the
hierarchy of needs to say that people
inherently seek self-actualization when
they feel like they're reaching their
full potential and along the way they
must meet certain needs and when they do
they're more likely to have what he
calls peak experiences he defines these
as moments of the highest happiness
where people feel like they've found
their place in the world I sent these
definitions off to the student body of
the GSB and I asked them have you ever
had any peak experiences the answers
work great this is just a snippet one of
them was from someone who served in
Afghanistan as a pilot and after a
particularly challenging mission he said
he literally felt a calming state of
Nirvana this was impactful because of
all of the responses I got his was the
only one that described a time when he
was at work and he was serving our
country in Afghanistan
these are the moments that make life
worth living for when you feel so much
joy and love and you feel like you found
your place in this world this is exactly
what I was looking for that defines the
amazing trips and the transformational
trips if we can't find these peak
experiences when we're at work when will
we when will you getting the most out of
your vacation takes a lot of practice
and a little bit of knowledge and to
help you with that I created a framework
gabby's hierarchy of vacation and at the
base at the minimum you need to
disconnect and take your vacation days
next you need to understand that too
many expectations are setting you up for
disaster because things will go wrong
and when they do you want to try and
find a little bit of pleasure in them
but when the things go right you want to
make sure that those are the memorable
experiences and you remember them and
when you do you'll be set up for peak
experiences my trips have taken me all
over the world and so much has gone
wrong I have lost dozens of passports
literally and yes I've been
strip-searched in Israel but I have also
had those rare moments of joy and
happiness where I have felt in Wonder
and awe of the world my hope for you is
that you have on-time departures and
toilets that you're familiar with
and that you have many many peak
experiences along the way I hope you
enjoy your vacation thank you